a lot of people are saying right now
that after shouldn't express their
opinions when it comes to politics but
the truth is actors are activists no
matter what good evening fellow
sag-aftra members and everyone at home
and everyone in airports that belong in
my America you are a part of the fabric
of who we are and we love you and we
welcome you
we also welcome you to the 23rd annual
screen actors guild awards sunday
night's screen actors guild awards were
met with heavy political dialogue from
both presenters and award recipients my
father fled religious persecution in
nazi-occupied France and I'm an American
patriot and I love this country and
because I love this country I am
horrified by its blemishes and this
immigrant band we know that it's going
to be up to us and all of you probably
two to keep telling stories that show
what unites us is stronger than the
forces that seek to divide us my mother
is a [ __ ] Dane minister I'm a Muslim
she didn't do backflips when I called
her to tell her i converted 17 years ago
please donate to the aclu to protect the
rights and liberties of people across
this country we will get past the lies
we will hunt monsters and when we are
all awesome it's the hypocrisy and the
casual violence of certain individuals
and institutions we will as per Chief
Jim hopper punch some people in the face
when they seek to destroy
[Applause]
thank you for this responsibility thank
you
[Music]
you